[Music]
happy anniversary
love birds kendall jenner and nba star
derrick booker
celebrated one year in a relationship
together over the weekend
thanks yeah i'm excited to commemorate
their relationship milestone
the couple shared rare romantic photos
of their travels and intimate time
together
on instagram among the snaps booker also
shared this video of a romantic sunset
scene even to be able to do this once a
year it's really special
jenner and booker were first spotted
together on a road trip in april of 2020
since then they've kept their blossoming
relationship
pretty low-key you know i've gotten to a
comfortable space and it's getting to be
just a part of my life in march a source
told et that things have gotten more
serious between the two saying quote
devin is really laid back and not all
about fame or being in the spotlight all
the time
which kendall really likes the source
added that he makes her feel
comfortable and safe and he's super
respectful which are all qualities
she loves text our family group chat
that you just got engaged oh my god
mom's gonna be like what is happening
but it's believable so i will do it
last month the model pranked her family
by telling them she and booker were
taking their relationship to the next
level
while playing truth or dare in a video
for kourtney kardashian's lifestyle site
push
hi no no you're alive
along with kylie her sisters kim and
chloe also had a shocked but excited
reaction
but which gave kendall some reassurance
why would you do that i know it was so
fun well at least we know you guys will
be excited when the day comes i know
you guys are so hyped
you